von der produktentwicklung bis zu einem
produkt kooperieren mit einrichtungen
für menschen mit handicap und legen alle
prozesse darauf aus unsere produkte in
handarbeit nachfüllen zu lassen
mega idee finde ich richtig cool also
muss ich immer sagen ein release ist in
amerika opfer dann prost oder hey leute
was gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ja da hätte ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut leute damit vor
zwei drei vier tagen ich weiß gar nicht
mehr genau kam wie ihr von mir ich das
neue adventskalender aus dem supermarkt
das waren so standarddünger was es
dieses jahr gibt und in diesem video und
schon gesagt wenn ihr irgendwelche
ausgefallenen kalender kennen die
vielleicht auch ein bisschen teurer sind
dann schickt mir die mal und ihr habt
mir wirklich ganz viele geschickt ich
habe auch ein bisschen selber
recherchiert und ich muss sagen mit
hilfe eines adventskalender herstellers
wenn ich jetzt mal so die vertreiben
weil diese dinger ich habe mir hat die
coolsten rausgesucht dann den
herstellern geschrieben auf die bock
haben mir zur verfügung zu stellen für
das video und da waren sie direkt dabei
auch mega cool deswegen ich habe dir
heute selber bezahlen kann man ja mal
sagen so kleines sponsoring aber ich
kein geld oder sonstiges wir haben hier
drei kalender wirklich hochwertige dinge
kosten alle so um die 50 euro
und ich habe mir gedacht geschaut direkt
mal rein oder so und zwar kommen die
alle von den trachten sind wir stets
foxi land ja also wir machen ganz viele
adventskalender
wie gesagt noch mal danke ich einfach so
aus zufall so anfangen und den dann
region oder wie man was für 117 oder gut
ich habe mir drei ausgesucht ich weiß
dann wären einer veganen das war noch
einer war aus amerika also mit
amerikanischen inhalt und einer bar mit
inhalt aus den 80ern können wir auch
interessant werden oder lässt das
advents kalender video gab ein bisschen
heikel weil ich da mich über diese
bücher beschwert habe tut mir leid
hoffentlich sind hier keine bücher drin
so was sieht nach dem amerikanischen ab
seit ich da war viel viel coolere ich
hoffe da war nichts drin dass die kugel
aus oder das ist verdammt cool und ich
könnte euch immer kurzen foto ein wo ich
gemerkt hat wie gesagt knapp 50 euro
kostet und ich bin jetzt gespannt ob
sich das am grund aber geht stark davon
aus also so lange da mal was anderes als
schokolade drin ist kann sich ein
gewaltiger es hört sich schon gut an
machen wir das jetzt so dass wir einen
kästchen nach dem anderen auch machen
oder soll ich mal wieder auf stützen
nicht auf schluss nicht auf besonders
gut haben dann fangen wir mal mit der
einst an komme ich manchmal so ries gibt
es auch nicht in deutschland keine
ahnung ich muss jetzt nicht ich muss
jetzt auch nicht alles probieren wir
machen einfach mal weiter
und das was mich dann am ende am meisten
interessiert probiere ich da noch ok wo
ist in die 2 bitte bitte hier
juli lemonheads also irgendwas mit
kaugummis oder so interessant und die
drei hier habe ich schon als schokolade
denke das mache ich mal kurz auf erfolg
leyen
das sind mehrere drin da stehen wir das
gleich das einmal schokolade nochmal zu
4000 tirol brauchen die schokolade alter
dieser war stark hier an der seite steht
auch ein text drauf muss ich mal kurz
vorlesen ok soziales engagement wird bei
uns großgeschrieben mit boxee dann
möchten wir ein unternehmen aufbauen
welches sich von beginn an sozial
engagiert unsere produkte werden fast
ausschließlich von menschen mit handicap
befüllt von der produktentwicklung bis
zu meinem produkt kooperieren wir mit
einrichtung für menschen mit handicap
und legen alle prozesse darauf aus
unserer produkte in handarbeit führen zu
lassen
megamind idee finde ich richtig cool
also muss ich immer sagen größeren raus
er hat meine vollste unterstützung wenn
er noch ein paar kalender schick
natürlich
kommen wir zu 95 euro ist in die fünf
hast du nie 5 gesehen dass hier auch das
motiv so fahren finde ich schon
das ist sehr aufwändig ja beim scan nur
ein
na ja schon wie sie es bald ja also das
sind wie gesagt vermutlich alles sachen
die man in amerika kaufen kann sowas
habe ich hier auch noch nie gesehen
interessant probiere ich gleich mal was
haben wir als nächstes nummer sechs
nikolaus exklusiven küstennähe ich hab
doch diese hoffnung habe ich auch
gemacht centers kristler kennst du das
ich bin ziemlich normal findet ihr auch
größer ist das wie die man auf dem eis
kaufen kann das in amerika kauft also
hinten gibt es in jedem laden alle gehen
darauf ab sich feiern da schmeckt nach
nichts finde ich du kaufst noch nicht so
mein fall
daniel abt zehn packungen davon
mitgenommen nach deutschland das
schmeckt ja ich mache mal ein bisschen
speed 09 unter der 29
jetzt habe ich zwei aufmacht noch nie da
freut sich das kind ja richtig gestern
gab es noch nie was gibt heute bekommen
wir machen jetzt einfach alle auf
außerdem 24 okay die kommt dann am ende
wollten
genau das ist wahrscheinlich ein auto
gut schon drin
[Musik]
jetzt würde ich das mal so ich glaube
wir haben alles jetzt ist natürlich die
frage
juni um ins das kenne ich das gibts doch
auch in deutschland so ähnlich mit
diesem ding was man tippen kann anderes
regelt auf jeden fall enorm was haben
wir hier noch johann also wirklich
interessante produkt bei natürlich muss
man sagen 50 euro ist ein stolzer preis
ganz klar aber das sind alles produkte
die wir hier in deutschland vermutlich
nicht haben dann haben wir ein cooles
design
wir haben wirklich abwechslung was die
produkte angeht und hier werden menschen
mit handicap arbeitsplätze geboten
von daher kann ich wirklich nur sagen
absolut daumen nach oben lohnt sich und
jetzt machen wir mal weiter
ich wollte ich wollte mich noch ein paar
sachen probieren und natürlich auch die
24 testen
o
speziell punktzahl 2 das ist pfeiffer
mit umsorgen von schokolade oder so
parisi stories sieht ein bisschen aus
wie laien
das würde ich auch zugeben ja gut da
haben wir die noch wahrscheinlich
amerikanischer mauer am ersatz oder
beweist was da auch cool wäre es noch so
ein zettel wie bei denen es ums boxen
stimmen dass wir auch mit zeigt gibt es
übrigens wieder essens boxen
es soll diese variieren ein paar neue
hier eintreffen habe ich gehört
den wollte testen hieß es weiter
das sind so also wie es ist in amerika
auch verdammt groß oder kaiser haben wir
noch nichts weiß dass die nummer 24 war
dass ich will irgendwie alles auf was
das denn nach terry
nur ein kurzes dazu naja ist ja auch
schlecht wenn ich als alles schon
probieren weil dann habt ihr gar keine
geschmacklichen überraschung mehr zu
hause wenn er sagt es ist ein eisberg
hat also 24
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt bisschen
spannender musik bitte danke dass du
nicht kennst auch das hast du jetzt geht
das habe ich letztes getestet das ist
nämlich neun läufen auf den markt
gekommen das machen wir weiter
wir haben hershey's cookies und cream
hier muss ich sagen das habe ich auf
keiner seite gesehen das hat mich
angelächelt und da stand ganz dick jetzt
neue traum und die dachten sich scheiße
passt nicht rein
was kann man da machen das ist ja das
habe ich schon presse naja hab leute ich
muss sagen auch jeden fall ein
spannender kalender
ich hoffe dass es noch spannender wird
was die nächsten kalender angeht
trotzdem verlinkt ich euch natürlich in
der video beschreibung kann nur
anschauen ich dafür absolut kein geld
habe ich gern noch macht eingebüßt zur
verfügung stellen und wir sind uns dann
wenn die feuerwehr vorbei gefahren ist
weil es gibt kurze zwischensequenzen mir
und danke europa polizei wir sehen uns
morgen 19 uhr wieder auf instagram
heissig alex wie da wird natürlich will
man diese lehrerkalender jetzt verlost
abonniert den kanal aktive die glocke
und ihr könnt mir sehr gerne in den
kommentaren und bei instagram weitere
kalender zu schicken die ich bestellen
soll und anpassen soll
haut rein
[Musik]